[Musica]
salve voglio iniziare questo racconto
partendo da una parola una parola greca
tecne che significa arte ma significa
anche tecnica tecnologia saper fare le
cose perché voglio iniziare da questa
parola perché nella nostra cultura
occidentale tecne significa processo
evolutivo e processo evolutivo che è
portato avanti
sembra strano ma dagli artisti se ci
pensate
tutto quello che è tecnologia è stato
molto importante per gli artisti in
tutta la storia dell'arte
pensiamo alla stessa prospettiva
all'inizio avevamo con giotto l'immagine
bidimensionale che già quasi si spingerà
verso la prospettiva poi arriva
brunelleschi e riesce a mettere a far
convergere tutte le linee dell'impianto
prospettico una novità incredibile
cominciavamo ad avere la percezione
chiara dello spazio ma in tempi più
recenti perché voglio spostare proprio
il discorso alloggi io faccio il regista
multimediale voglio raccontarvi anche
come la tecno è proprio la tec ne ha
cambiato la mia vita
tornando all'oggi se ripensiamo per il
pre ritratto il ritratto era ovviamente
quella
acquisizione di status che un potente
poteva permettersi posare per un grande
pittore e direi io esisto
quando nasce la fotografia i ritrattisti
entrano in crisi perché la fotografia
sapeva fare molto meglio ritratto
rispetto a come lo faceva la pittura e
per i pittori cominciano a fare altro
nascono dell'avanguardia nascono gli
espressionisti nascono i fori cioè
cominciano a raccontare qualcos'altro
qualcosa dell'animo umano cominciano a
entrare dentro al di là della della
figura
ecco che l'arte
rivoluziona la sua essenza attraverso
una rivoluzione di tecnè di tecnologia
ma non solo iniziano così a nascere
altre possibilità che poi si innestano
con i lumière nel cinema pensate alla
stazione lazio tutt la gente si alza
presa la paura che il treno arrivasse
addosso alloro incredibile il dinamismo
diventare ecco che nascono attraverso
questi passaggi
modificazioni potentissime di linguaggio
io ho detto questo per capire un
pochettino quello che a me è successo io
ho vissuto il pilot di transizione
proprio tra l'al analogico e digitale
quando avevo 15 anni
per la fine degli esami
avevo chiesto un regalo che un regalo
che mi ha cambiato la vita un
sintetizzatore
voi sapete così un synth e è uno
strumento
analogico di allora comunque attraverso
le onde potevi creare dei suoni che non
esistevano in natura cioè potevi
sintetizzare la musica questo è un
quindicenne ha cambiato proprio
all'ordine delle idee perché perché mi
sono trovato di fronte a quello che in
inglese si chiama play to play giocare
che vuol dire però anche creare fare
qualcosa che non esisteva e in più la
dinamica del registrare ciò che hai
creato quindi vederlo vivere al di fuori
di te questa è stata la scoperta della
musica dall'inizio come uno smanettone
cioè smanettava proprio sul synth poi
dopodiché ho cominciato a seguire un
corso di composizione di musica
elettronica ea scoprire che tutto questo
aveva un'origine molto interessante cioè
la creazione di un qualcosa che
rifletteva un cambiamento cambiamento di
che cosa di tecnologia sempre di tecnè
cominciò ad appassionarmi all'arte e
cominciò a giocare con l'arte con
linguaggi dell'arte e comincia a fare
teatro quindi come c'è la mia componente
multimediale vivete faccio il regista
multimediale in quegli anni stiamo
parlando della fine degli anni 80
cominciava a quel movimento che si
chiamava teatro multimediale con i
magazzini criminali
gaia scienza gruppi molto interessanti
che usavano anche il video dentro dentro
le loro rappresentazioni teatrali quindi
un incontro tra real e spazio scenico e
virtuale ecco che li mi emerge un
concetto importantissimo che voglio
raccontarvi ed è il concetto di
environment cioè di spazio
abitato artisticamente cioè si esce
dalla componente
bidimensionale del quadro della school
dura o del teatro come tempo invece per
entrare nelle installazioni
ecco questo è stato l'altra chiave che
poi mi ha spinto durante la mia laurea
in storia dell'arte a vincere una
piccola borsa di studio e volare a
parigi ea parigi entro al centre
pompidou nel reparto di videoarte allora
c'era la video arte in voga non era
ancora interattiva era pre inter attiva
cioè c'erano degli allestimenti famosi
sono quelli di dan june paik
wolf vostell charlotte moormann cioè
nomi accreditati insieme haller cam che
il centro di musicologia di musica
elettronica che facevano una cosa
straordinaria cioè cominciavano a dire
il pubblico non vive più l'arte
solamente così con una dimensione qua
dello spettatore ma entra dentro l'opera
d'arte la abita e vive una componente
sinestesica cioè di più sensi insieme
quindi la vista l'olfatto
addirittura anche il gusto cioè una
dimensione immersiva questa cosa
ovviamente vi porta a scrivere la tesi
entusiasta e approfondire il tema dopo
di che torna in sardegna e faccio la
prima mostra di arte lettera unica in
italia alla galleria comunale aveva
trovato veramente una grande apertura
grande fiducia e realizzò una
installazione si chiama beta è la casa
del dio dove aveva costruito una tomba
dei giganti c'è una tomba dei giganti
vero e proprio voi sapete un monumento
megalitico usando pietre vere con
l'aiuto di un grande scultore pinuccio
sciola pincio capisce l'idea mi aiuta a
tagliare queste queste pietre e a
inserire nella parte mancante gli
schermi quindi tu vedevi la roccia lo
vedete anche nelle immagini la roccia e
dentro la roccia praticamente il monitor
che dalla roccia che si apre come una
sorta di memoria se voi pensate che in
quegli anni dall analogico si passano al
digitale cioè il silicio cioè quel
qualcosa che ci permetterà di
programmare le immagini cominciavano le
atteggiamenti interattivi cioè non più
un'opera ferma di fronte a noi ma
un'opera che diventa dinamica cioè può
interagire con noi quella mostra fu
fondamentale perché mi portò
una grande artista come maria lai la
sola cito perché poi abbiamo lavorato
tanto assieme
diceva vivere e aprire una porta dopo
l'altra per vedere ciò che ci riserva
l'imprevedibile questa imprevedibilità
lia venne venne un professore di colonia
una grande scuola con stop sulle firme
dian legata alle mete di boston e nel
giro di un mese la mia vita cambiò
perché dovete partire a colori nel senso
che ho vinto una borsa di studio di
dottorato di ricerca e quindi lì partì a
colonia e fu catapultato in un in un
mondo del futuro nel senso che
ovviamente al tempo immaginate queste
grandi stazioni di montaggio silicon
graphics costavano centinaia di migliaia
di euro di euro ce ne sono se diciamo in
lire 100 milioni 200 mila euro c'era una
barriera d'accesso incredibili una
ripetuta ormai permettermi queste queste
tecnologie come la tutta la tuta
interattiva la possibilità di rimuovere
i fotogrammi col proprio corpo quindi
arriva a colonia e mi specializzo in
regia multimediale e lì la possibilità
di fare delle cose straordinari mi hanno
fatto prima scenografia virtuale per il
concerto ad hyde park a new york di
pavarotti domingo carreras oppure il
progetto babele di parigi dell'unesco
cioè la metafora delle linguaggi creando
una torre multimediale fatta di tanti
muri e comincia il concetto di link
dipende stiamo parlando degli anni
novanta nel 93 dal 93 al 96 deleted
iperlink di per media cioè la
possibilità di entrare e interagire con
con testi visivi testuali e conti con
testi grafici ora questo questo
passaggio per me è stato un acceleratore
un ace lettere che sembrava portarmi via
dalla sardegna invece cosa succede
c'è stata una breve pausa per me di
ritorno in italia
subito dopo il dottorato sono finito a
milano da lavorare per la disney per la
buona vista una società della disney e a
fare i cd rom allora uscivano i cd rom
sistemi interattivi con cui potevi a
raccontare delle storie però stavo
lasciando la cosa più bella cioè quello
vive scordiamo maria lai e aprire una
porta dopo l'altra per vedere cosa ci
riserva l'imprevedibile stava diventando
tutto troppo prevedibile torna in
sardegna con un grande amico che poi
diventato il socio di tante avventure
romeo scaccia
facciamo un concorso di idee c'era
questo concorso della rai
per un'idea innovativa tecnica di
tecnologie e decidiamo di fare un
concerto multimediale da tre città
europee diverse quindi facciamo un
collegamento con questi robot si
chiamano disklavier che erano la
possibilità di suonare il pianoforte in
remoto
stiamo parlando di fine anni 90 adesso
sembra fattibilissimo via milli eccetera
eccetera
lì era una scommessa perché c'è la ii e
se di eni non c'era nemmeno la dafne la
fibra nella rete veloce facciamo questa
cosa in diretta da macerata veniamo
selezionati per l'idea è avviene il
miracolo che funziona cioè se riusciamo
a far suonare tre musicisti d'atri città
europee che non si vedevano tre di loro
con il pianoforte che nello spettacolo
praticate si animavano much che
magicamente da soli sponsor di
quell'evento era l'allora nascente
nascente tiscali è a quel punto
l'avventura continua nel senso che
renato soru ci dice perché non create
qualcosa di innovativo qui in sardegna
quindi romeo veniva da una scaccia
avveniva dall'olanda io venivo dalla
germania torniamo in sardegna e fondiamo
una nostra società la coda multimedia
con cui creiamo il primo canale
nazionale italiano di arte un canale
internet che nasce in sordina all'inizio
con facevamo tutto noi facciamo gli
articoli i collegamenti video dopo di
che arriviamo ad avere oltre 15
dipendenti e la cosa magica è stato che
diventiamo il primo canale d'arte
italiano e primocanale d'arte con cui
facciamo degli scoop mondiali perché
pubblichiamo 18 lettere di michelangelo
buonarroti ne dite facciamo per due
volte la per primi la biennale di
venezia e poi incredibile portiamo la
diretta della arrivo di velasquez in
italia cioè questo pittore lo
raccontiamo dall'interno quindi questo
ci cambia la vita perché cominciamo
da una struttura artistica tecnologica
insieme
creiamo un format che era il format di
un canale d'arte italiano e da lì
avviene qualcosa altro questa prima
esplosione centrifuga con tanti giovani
di allora giovani sardi che si mettono
insieme raccontano al mondo l'arte
italiana dalla sardegna ma
paradossalmente fare una cosa molto
molto interessante cioè raccontano la
propria cultura al mondo e nasce così
una serie di mostre itineranti che
portano la sardegna nel mondo quindi
abbiamo fatto la vostra sugli scrittori
sardi alla buchmesse di francoforte
gramsci dedalus satta raccontati come
dei pozzi pozzi della memoria dove il
visitatore si avvicinava toccava
quest'acqua di memoria e poi apparivano
i racconti di tutti questi scrittori in
maniera interattiva quindi con link con
la possibilità di vedere i video tutto
in una progettazione però coordinata tra
spazio interfaccia e tutto ciò che
veniva raccontato perché c'era proprio
quella reminiscenza che dicevo prima
della installazione dell'environment
cioè il visitatore che entra e vive
fondamentalmente una esperienza qualcosa
che lo cattura che lo emoziona che dà un
senso di vita di vitale che non sia
qualcosa
the mad and the favola non narrate no ma
qualcosa che mi tira dentro mi tira
dentro proprio la l'evento è successo
qualcosa e facciamo anche una cosa molto
bella museo permanente che avete quali i
tenores dei tenores e grazie a questo
museo poi comincia anche il percorso di
poter vivere l'esperienza dei tenores
come se ce l'avessi lì di fronte a te
con degli schermi che sono interattivi e
come un direttore d'orchestra puoi
attivare le voci questo ricordo
esattamente come succede
mi sono trovato un giorno in una foresta
insieme ai tenores di bitti giravo
fianco eto'o cantate intorno a me l'orso
messi e magicamente in una notte
stellata hanno cominciato a cantare con
le loro voci
lo ha detto io devo ricostruire questa
sensazione dall'interno e ne ho fatto
insieme ai designer proprio la struttura
in cui sono uno a uno cioè rispetto alla
persona sono proprio la grandezza
naturale quindi a il video con un
sistema interattivo quindi anche un
lavoro di software molto molto
approfondito perché questo lavoro si fa
con tante figure professionali io lavoro
come regista ma ci sono tanti che
lavorano ovviamente sulle interfacce
sulla grafica e sui sistemi anche di
design dentro a questo lavoro poi
diciamo dei ritratti e benfatto ritratti
interattivi dei più grandi imprenditori
esistenti con la boccone sole 24 ore ci
raccontavamo questi imprenditori che
diventeranno dei modelli però tu ti
avvicinavi tocca viglio chi è il quadro
si apriva e avevi ovviamente la visione
di questi imprenditori oppure toccava il
naso ed erano come dei ritratti che
proprio stavano di fronte a tema si
muovevano vi abbiamo dovuto fare un
sistema molto interessante di
interfaccia di tutti i fotogrammi del
filmato cioè si chiama interfaccia
dinamica cioè i fotogrammi possono
diventare apertura di qualcosa che sta
dietro e che diventa racconto
metaracconto cioè ciò che ci piace
sempre raccontare il genius loci delle
cose dalla sardegna quindi hanno
cominciato a raccontare al mondo e con
linguaggi del mondo della multimedialità
e della contemporaneità i nostri tesori
così è venuto per il museo delle
maschere mamoiada abbiamo raccontato al
mondo in mamutones avevano fatto proprio
uno speciale su art è la televisione
tedesca e questo museo delle maschere e
stato best experience premiato come
esperienza vincente perché raccontava in
maniera emozionale con una multivisione
cioè con la possibilità di avere gli
schermi intorno a te dei mamutones che
però si accendono e interagiscono con la
presenza dello spettatore una visione
antropologica e poetica grazie alla
bachisio bandinu un grande antropologo
uno che ha veramente nel cuore il dna
della sardegna riesce magicamente a
riproporlo con una voce caldissima
utilizzato siamo riusciti a utilizzare
quindi le interfacce più contemporanee
per raccontare qualcosa che invece c'è a
forte appartenenza cioè racconta di noi
del nostro spirito ma anche ci proietta
in una in un linguaggio della
contemporaneità e così è avvenuto anche
per il museo delle stelle un planetario
innovativo che abbiamo fatto a per
cagliari dove c'è la possibilità di
vivere un'esperienza full dom cioè
essere immersi nelle stelle avere tutti
i meteoriti che la spassano avere il
fisco lo verso sistemi di percezione
delle stelle prime diversi giorni degli
anni dei secoli
tutto questo per dire che una cosa
fondamentale della progettazione
multimediale della regia multimediale e
sila tecne ma è anche quella capacità di
emozione quella capacità ovviamente di
poesia che le cose possono esprimere e
che si tira fuori insieme agli altri
insieme a tante persone che lavorano con
te che possono essere ovviamente i tuoi
referenti scientifici ma anche i tecnici
informatici gli attori e chi in qualche
modo con le musiche ravviva tutto il tuo
impianto di di comunicazione è un lavoro
che ovviamente non si fa da solo quando
è iniziato
mi chiedevano che lavoro fa il ricevere
vista multimediale cioè dovevi spiegare
esattamente cosa significa installazione
va in un po come ho fatto io con voi
adesso
ora ovviamente una realtà perché viviamo
la nostra interfaccia con un telefonino
che può fare tutto questo ed è tutto più
facile all'inizio quando iniziato c'era
veramente la difficoltà di mettere
insieme tutto con le tecnologie di
allora e adesso proprio con la nuova
tecnologia noi ci stiamo dedicando una
cosa molto bella
c'è unire arte natura e tecnologia mi ha
fatto un lavoro alfa poco di 500
chilometri a piedi per la sardegna fino
alla corsica raccontando gli antichi
cammini cammina heras delle transumanze
ma anche dei nove nari questi luoghi
meravigliosi dove stavano i nostri i
nostri padri ma ancor prima i nuragici
perché ci sono dei dei luoghi né
novenari dove stavano dei santuari
biologici meravigliose c'è unire
attraverso le tecnologie
arte natura e stupore della nostra terra
ed era quella che adesso primo stiamo
facendo con due parti un parco
letterario multimediale di grazia
deledda a galtellì in cui praticamente
entry come un set nei racconti di del ed
è attraverso un'app che si chiama genius
loci e stata gia sperimentata convinti
il tuo corpo diventa capace di
interfacciarsi cioè ti avvicina una
quercia e parte un brano in automatico
oppure
sollevi il tuo corpo su una roccia e
senti qualcosa altro cioè scoprite in
una dinamica teatrale cinematografica il
layer gli strati di comunicazione che
spesso sono celati noi siamo molto bravi
per quanto riguarda il vantare la nostra
terra ma poco bravi nel raccontarla cioè
nel raccontarla con con tutti gli
aspetti più più vivi che ci sono questo
invece la tecnologia ci può aiutare a
tirare fuori a tecnologia come human ice
technologies cioè umanizzare le
tecnologie non subire il linguaggio
degli altri subire la tecnologia come
qualcosa già scritto ma come un vero
proprio linguaggio parlare la nostra
lingua con le tecnologie del futuro
[Applauso]
[Musica]